il y à huit mois avec l'apparition d'un
mystérieux virus venu de chine le monde
entier s'est interrogé sur sa provenance
et son apparition si soudaine très vite
des spécialistes ont conclu que le covic
19 avaient probablement pour origine le
pangolin une théorie relayée par tous
les médias mais très vite tempérés par
certains pour eux cette explication
serait bancal et la thèse selon laquelle
le virus aurait pu s'échapper d'un
laboratoire est beaucoup plus probable
puisque on sait que sur laboratoire p4 à
one est spécialisé dans les coronavirus
est-ce qu'en fin de compte quelqu'un
n'aurait pas pu se contaminer sauf que
très vite des scientifiques et
spécialistes sont opposés à cette
théorie expliquant que tout cela était
simplement impossible du tout une
théorique et critique il n'y a aucun
problème
le je me demande quand même si on n'est
pas là dans une vision un peu un peu
complotistes pourtant en juillet la
virologue chinoise ligne médiane a donné
une interview à la chaîne fox news pour
expliquer qu'elle avait travaillé sur un
virus similaires en laboratoire et que
pour elle il s'agissait bien d'un
accident des révélations qui l'aurait
obligé à quitter le pays je ne pouvais
révélé les preuves en janvier sont
risqué d'être menacée mais je travaille
maintenant avec un groupe de chercheurs
aux états unis et nous allons publier
très prochainement toutes les preuves
scientifiques de cette origine humaine
en mars dernier la virologue avait aussi
affirmé que la chloroquine était
efficace contre le coronavirus il y à ce
traitement précoce l'hydroxyde
chloroquine dont nous savons qu'il peut
être utilisé mais ils ont fait tout leur
possible pour empêcher les gens
d'utiliser ce médicament en répandant
des rumeurs sur ce médicament sans
danger si l'université pour laquelle
elle a travaillé conteste ces
révélations aujourd'hui cette question
autour d'une possible fuite d'un labo et
remise sérieusement sur la table par des
chercheurs du cnrs
alors pensez vous que le coronavirus
wati sud en laboratoire ce soir
l'épidémiologiste robert sebag et sur
notre plateau pour répondre à nos
questions si robert sauvage est là
infectiologue à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière vraiment un honneur pour
nous de vous avoir ce soir merci
beaucoup donc robert déjà première
question le masque c'est important pas
en avant on allait dire que c'est très
bien ce que vous faites la mer soit pas
partout sur d'autres plateaux non je
pense comme infectiologues et
spécialistes il faut montrer l'exemple
d'accord brave redonner agriculteurs
fait confiance en toutes les mesures
nécessaires ici mais je pense que c'est
donc rejoindre les shows de masse ne
sert à rien ils disent des bêtises pour
parler de l'interview de et n'aurait
coûté tout tous les infectiologues tous
les responsables d'infections
respiratoires
il ya une logique
vous prenez n'importe quel précis de
médecine infectieuse sur les infections
respiratoires le masque c'est très
important mais les mains aussi
ainsi donc un nu portée mais également
le masque dans l'es2 alors merci d'être
avec nous parce que c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment on n'arrête pas d'entendre que la
thèse d'un virus issue d'un laboratoire
et que le niveau on a vu des articles
très sérieux dans des la presse vraiment
extrêmement sérieux ce week-end sortir
qui disait que de plus en plus on irait
peut-être que c'est une erreur un
accident en laboratoire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
d'abord quand on aborde ce sujet il faut
être extrêmement prudent
bien sûr parce que c'est l'ouverture si
vous voulez à toute les complots tous
les délires quand ce dont on est sûr on
est sûr de quelque chose c'est que c'est
un virus naturel
il n'a pas été manipulée après vous avez
deux possibilités soit la possibilité si
vous voulez pas y revenir la
chauve-souris un animal intermédiaire on
commence à douter sur le pangolin mais
notre animal intermédiaires et un
passage d'espèce c'est à dire une
maladie animale qui va passer chez
l'homme soit ce virus a été cultivées en
laboratoire pour faire de la recherche
et qui aurait un échappement
mais c'est pas un virus qui étaient
manipulés aujourd'hui on est capable
quand on prend la structure génétique
d'un virus de voir s'il a été touché sur
si on a fait ce qu'on appelle des
chimères c'est-à-dire de disjoindre
d'autres d'autres particules d'autres
virus il fasse qu'en ce moment c'est
vrai qu'au départ on accusait cet animal
que je connais c'est maintenant le
pangolin voilà on en a entendu parler
partout et puis de plus en plus même les
gens les plus sérieux vous disent c'est
pas voulu mais peut-être qu'il ya eu une
erreur en laboratoire un accident qui
fait que ce virus est sorti est-ce que
c'est déjà arrivé des erreurs en
laboratoire menant un virus ça pourrait
arriver car ça pourrait arriver alors on
a on a parlé d'un certain nombre
d'épidémie d'épidémie grippale si vous
voulez et de fièvre de marburg aussi il
y aurait eu peut-être peut-être un
erreur en laboratoire la fumée là dessus
si vous voulez le gros point
d'interrogation c'est qu'on n'a pas
identifiés l'hôte intermédiaire alors je
vais m'expliquer on sait que des passes
oui ouais aussi qu'au départ les chauves
souris
c'est d'ailleurs très intéressant elles
ont dans leur organisme
dizaines et des dizaines de virus dont
des coronavirus et d'ailleurs on se
demande on se dit mais quel est le
système immunitaire la chauve souris qui
leur permet d'être protégé date ça c'est
le premier point et on sait que ya un
coronavirus qui est très proche de celui
donc fameux qu'ovide 19 que nous avons
donc ça serait la source la sauce
primitive et donc des chercheurs peuvent
étudier il ya des gens qui vont chercher
des chauves souris dans des grottes au
vietnam en chine et qui étudie qui
peuvent faire un certain nombre de
travaux sur ces virus ensuite ce qu'on a
pensé si vous voulez c'est que la chauve
souris
elle s'alimente de bégonias ces deux
fruits particulier sur des arbres et
puisqu'elle urines
donc les fruits sont touchés par l'uriné
il peut y avoir des fourmis aussi qui
viennent et puis un animal qui vient
manger ces fourmis qui se contaminent
alors à un moment on a dit ça peut être
le pangolin parce que vous savez que nos
amis chinois aiment beaucoup les animaux
sauvages et on a dit le pont gola pour
être et puis on mange le pangolin puis
un passage des espèces d'une maladie du
pont gaulin qui va se répandre chez
l'homme et ça a été ça a été le cas ça a
été le cas vous êtes juste il ya deux
autres coronavirus qui rend qui a
entraîné des ennemis à le strass
injurieux 2002 2003 et le maire ce au
moyen orient
là on a trouvé notre intermédiaire
c'était une civette ce petit animal
qu'on trouve qu'on trouvait dans
beaucoup de marchés en chine
et puis le maire s'était plus lié aux
dromadaires d'accord voyez au dromadaire
là on n'a pas trouvé cet intermédiaire
c'est donc pour et donc pourquoi donc
pourquoi est beaucoup de gens là aiment
entendre un chien par exemple on a parlé
des chiens viverrins d'une catégorie de
chez un particulier qui pourrait être
porteur de ces robert ont pour l'instant
on n'a pas trouvé
donc c'est pour ça que la thèse d'un
accident au laboratoire a réapparu de
plus en plus est-ce que c'est
complètement utopique ou pas du tout si
vous voulez il faut surtout ne pas
penser que c'était quelque chose de
délibéré d'accord donc il ya eu des
recherches en laboratoire et qu'on soit
sorti dans la rue qu'on ait balancé une
fiole ra sur le mas et d'avoine on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui ce principe il n'y
a pas une manipulation
si vous voulez ce qu'on sait c'est que
le virus que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est un virus c'est naturel alors
l'origine après est ce que c'est une
origine
ça pourrait être dans laboratoire ce qui
est très important c'est déjà de se
poser la question des mesures de
sécurité alors en france les fameux p4p
3 il ya différents types de laboratoire
et de vérifier les mesures de sécurité
sur thur laboratoire justement juste en
30 secondes
on a vu aujourd'hui que le laboratoire
pfizer était très bien avancé sur un
vaccin est ce que c'est une source
d'espoir ou bien est ce que parce que
j'aimais écouter on est content non non
on est content on est on est content
parce que vous nous auriez dit les
spécialistes il ya huit mois
n'ayez pas peur en fin d'année 2020 vous
aurez un vaccin à lui arrêté vous
plaisantez
le soin que c'est tout ça mais qu'on
alors il faut savoir deux choses de
vaccins vous avez trois phases
importantes
je résume et vous avez la phase un
regard d'un petit peu s'il n'est pas
dangereux la phase 2 on voit s'il
entraîne des anticorps donc six pros
telle est la phase iii c'est une phase
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
regarder passer les trois premières
phases
alors vous allez en est à la phase iii
et il ya plus de 45000 je pense sujet
alors là vous devez séparé en deux
chiens dans plusieurs sens dur centres
en europe
parce que pour expérimenter il faut un
endroit où le virus circule donc il ya
eu les etats-unis le brésil et d'autres
pays en europe et donc on prend la
moitié placebo mais ils ne savent pas on
leur fait une injection leur d'ixelles
vaccins l'autre moitié les vaccins avant
d'avoir terminé cette étude on a regardé
et on a trouvé sur le groupe sans savoir
il ya des comités d'experts que 97 ou 98
personnes était atteint du virus
donc là on a dit baye ils viennent d'où
ces personnes on a regardé bien a dit
ben voilà il y en a neuf qui ont été
vaccinés mais tous les autres n'étaient
pas vaccinés et donc on a dit on a une
efficacité de ce vaccin relativement
important alors alors non non et c'est
important parce que attention faux
espoirs avec savoir mal à ça près
pourquoi je dis ça parce que d'abord il
va falloir qu'on vérifie si vous voulez
si tous les groupes de personnes qui ont
été pris dans cette expérimentation est
ce qu'il ya des personnes âgées à ce que
des personnes diabétiques est ce que les
personnes obèses les personnes jeunes
pour voir parce que ce vaccin il va il
va être répartie pour la majorité des
gens ça c'est le premier point
maintenant il faut attendre la fin de
l'étude et voir si on est une efficacité
de 90 % c'est rêver
1,6 et le graphique donc là pour la ccs
efficacité oui maintenant le deuxième
point c'est la sécurité
l'absence d'effets secondaires pourquoi
je dis ça parce que par définition le
vaccin il s'adresse à des casses des
personnes saines maison qu'on n'a pas
envie d'attraper quelques chaudes en
pleine forme en plus c'est une maladie
qui n'est pas mortelle dans 100% des cas
doxi donc il faut être sûr qu'ils aient
pas d'effets secondaires majeurs ça ça
va être beaucoup plus long ça va être
beaucoup plus dur ça va être au delà de
la phase 3 mais il faut d'abord que les
autorités sanitaires donne
l'autorisation
ça c'est le dernier point jet li a deux
autres points 1
c'est la fabrication parce qu'on en a
besoin c'est des millions si c'est pas
d'idée milliards et après toute la
logistique
donc ça c'est combien de temps à peu
près mais attendait d'abord ce que dit
ce que dit ce laboratoire se dit ce
laboratoire pfizer associé à une biotech
allemande
ils disent que ils vont fournir d'ici la
fin de l'année 2020 50 millions de doses
d'accord on sait qu'il faut deux doses
ça veut dire qu'on peut couvrir 25
millions de personnes d'accord et qui
pourrait fournir qui pourrait fournir en
2021 1,3 milliard de doses ce qui fait
650 millions de personnes est bien
calculé
houston où il est très bon merci ce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est qu'elle va être la durée de
protection là quand c'est qu'il faut
deux injections mais est-ce qu'il faudra
un rappel au bout d'un an
est ce que ça sera tous les ans comme
c'est le cas pour de la gagner les
bonnes nouvelles n'ont cédé excellente
nouvelle mais il faut être serein
il faut savoir que vous moi vos grands
parents vos parents n'auront pas tout de
suite
ce vaccin donc il faut être il faut être
prudent on va il va y avoir une
stratégie de prioriser un petit peu les
personnes va bien sûr en bénéficier de
ce vaccin ben moi c'est le cas roberge
bague infectiologue à l'hôpital de la
pitié salpêtrière pardon vous allez me
sign vous appellerai vous appellerez de
thurso bac de tout à l'heure mais kelly
vachiery docteur ce bac oui elle vous
demande sur le conseil ou pas le vaccin
on va le tester on va voir et puis bien
sûr apprécié si on voit ça vous savez
vous savez quel est notre inquiétude en
france huit mois très vite je me permets
je me plais colis qui nous attend il ya
eu non mais il ya eu des sondages qui
disent que 40 % 36 à 40 % des français
même s'il y avait un vaccin
efficace ne se fait pas vacciner à ça
moi ça me ça me fait très peur le pays
pasteur fut quand même très inquiétant
c'est vrai donc il va falloir expliquer
aux gens le bénéfice du vaccin
et si l'on veut en finir avec ce virus
l'immunité collective on en est loin
ça sera la vaccination